[Music]
if you're willing to be the content
creator all you have to do this is very
crazy it's only two simple things it's
gonna sound so ridiculous like a
grandmother this portion is like with me
so i think this is when you need to get
selfish like you need to ask your
question
hiring is guessing firing is knowing
like you got to go fast that's how you
get [ __ ] done that's how you figure
stuff out this
is the television
and the television is the radio
the 40s [ __ ]
george said gary take yourself off mute
as well
thanks joe hi gary
it's a pleasure to be here i'm from
bulgaria seven hours after your time at
the moment it's seven in the evening
i'm running a real estate brokerage it's
called primo and we have 30 agents here
in bulgaria and i'll be delighted to
discuss some questions with you thanks
again
are you sure you're not in my office my
friend yes uh i would love to be but
unfortunately i'm not
thanks for being here oh thanks man
uh and now to seattle washington jeremy
uh who's uh going to be bringing a bunch
of ceos into the 40s over the next few
months jeremy why don't you go ahead and
say hi to gary thanks joe good morning
gary jeremy hill from seattle run a
company called jb capital uh we invest
make credit investments across the sme
landscape across the country i've been
talking to joe and james for a while and
have
one of our portfolio companies ryan
along with us today so happy to share
some time
real pleasure my friend and with that
ryan hogan uh ryan keep yourself off
mutant say hi to gary
hey gary brian hogan uh co-founder and
ceo at hunt to killer
um i know that sounds pretty pretty
crazy but we send immersive murder
mysteries each month
um episodically and we've uh
we have our eyes on digital so great to
meet you
i love it real pleasure
and down here in cali we've got russell
mcdonald russell say hi to gary
hey gary how's it going russell mcdonald
i am a mortgage broker in the san
francisco bay area
real pleasure russell thanks for being a
part of this
thank you
and in california as well we've got
dylan dylan say hi
you're on mute buddy
hi gary this is dylan and uh i'm from
bay area as well uh
we run a direct consumer dental product
company called just into lab we make
custom night guard for people who grind
their teeth at night
very important product
yeah they help people sleep better
it's awesome real pleasure
thank we've got ace and jamie ace and
jamie say hi
hey gary how you doing buddy ace and
jamie here
real pleasure great to see you guys
uh we run fmo media out of long island
new york and we help businesses grow
their revenue through social media
marketing and we are pumped to be here
and learn uh so let's go back and we'll
start with george over in bulgaria
george uh you're got your moment in the
sun with gary um i'm gonna go ahead and
and say we're gonna try to aim for 12
minutes but uh bear with me so
george go ahead and start firing off
some questions for garyvee
joe uh gary first of all um sorry if i'm
being so nervous
second of all congrats on the video that
you post today on instagram and for no
video it really pumped me up for the 4g
so i'm really excited about it
talking about our real estate brokerage
i've heard you a lot of times saying
that if you do a real estate brokerage
it will be the best in the world i don't
doubt about it
um really i have two main issues i have
to ask you and both of them are lead
generation because i have two core
pillars in my business the first of all
is me generating sellers that sell
properties same in the us the inventory
is very low so we have to find
ways to you know to create
creatively attract sellers and do the
strategy i mean the
funnel and the second one is my skill is
obviously based on quality real estate
agents
we don't
specifically aim to attract experienced
agents
the idea is to communicate with the
world
the benefits of our company and we
recently launched a program of
100 commission for the agents you have
it in the states with
keller williams with exp realty they
have these cap commissions 100
commissions which actually after they uh
placed a specific amount of money in
their office for a 12-month period the
rest of the months until the 12 months
they take the commission's 100
which is good for us because we do our
annual budget and it's good for them
because they bring home a lot of money
which is really interesting
so so basically my question is how gary
would do the um
the gateway sailor attraction and the
real estate agent's attraction with
keeping in mind this hundred percent
um
let me break it down for you so i think
on the let's talk about the real estate
agents
and let's talk about it in real life how
six how many do you have
let's start with that
and and
what how does the percentage of
let's call it exceptional
good
and average of that you know what
percentage are exceptional of those 35
out of 35 people which is
like 15
and how many are good
then we have
let's say
well i have about five at the bottom so
that means that 20 are in the middle
so i think you know i think i think that
um
the the way to think about it is a
couple things one
you're only is if you're not going after
there's two ways not going after
experienced agents or going after
experienced agents right
to me i'm always going to go after nod
experience with a couple of experience
so you get a couple of experience
because you need it
but i would spend all my time and energy
on the training
so that you could take literally
bright-eyed bushy-tailed you know people
that just want to get into it
what i've noticed from a lot of real
estate brokerages is that they don't
have a good training program and they're
not actually committed to it they're
rolling the dice and they're hoping they
get good people they're not cultivating
good people
so the way i would do it is i would
spend more money than most people would
expect on one two three four or
me george me gary spending a lot more
time training up people
most people don't want to do that
because they always worry that well if i
trade them up if they get good they
might leave it's a waste of time the
problem is you're in the business of
people
right that's the same problem i have at
vaynermedia it doesn't stop me right and
when you're a good person and you do the
right thing you can have a situation
like i have with james and joe and many
people in my company where people stay a
long time not just a couple years so
that's the real answer to attracting
talent i think you know this you can get
a lot more people that are raw
that want to get in where you have to
spend more money than you are spending
or your time
is on the cultivating of people not uh
johnny's not johnny's not good you know
like you gotta end when you know the
bottom five aren't good
you need to
turn them and get rid of them in a nice
way in a human way
but they're taking up too much energy
i would throw the message and uh build
this machine of attracting of attracting
this unexperienced people
i mean
that
and i'll explain why in a second and
and really matters to your marketplace
so i have a very good understanding of
the global market
but i'm i'm not as up-to-date as i wish
i could be on the bulgarian market so we
have to talk about it and i thought i
might have walked in
when james orsini was talking about tick
tock and why i like it you know to me
it's always the same game
you know what i do know about bulgaria
with youtube and facebook is
and instagram is there's scale there
and i i believe for all of you from you
know christy with red vines to you to
everybody
everybody is underestimating how much
you can build a brand and build a
business through social media branding
branding
uh and so
some people have decided finally you can
do business through social media selling
but where the big disconnect in the
world is social media branding
so george you know the other thing is
how do you acquire somebody in bulgaria
who wants to maybe be a real estate
agent it's you
preferably or somebody else making
videos that say are you happy with your
job
are you happy
would you like to get into this industry
if you're naturally a good people person
and you have good work ethic this is a
very lucrative industry
comment and fill out this form on google
form
which then you would make a very good
google form where you would ask them to
make a video
you know after they answered a bunch of
questions and then you and your team
would go through a lot of them but the
applicants would come in heavy if you
ran a very smart
youtube pre-roll
campaign where you were making the
videos
and it was against
interest like soccer proper football or
against real estate you can go broad of
things that everybody likes in the
country food and wine i know the area
proper football but also your expertise
and you can see how the numbers work are
you getting better applicants from going
abroad because it's everybody or you
paying more for very narrow real estate
but you're getting better applicants you
run that math
and that becomes the same thing for
listings
and awareness it's just all
like your game
you've got 35 human beings that are
working to
find and sell
your job is to build brand it's no
different to why
uh you know i didn't i'll give you a
good example
i don't think ace and jamie are here
because they saw seven good ads on
instagram or facebook and we kept
retargeting them
we've built the best brand for what they
do this once they became aware of this
and
went through the mind process they're
like this is a good arbitrage for us
same for you right i mean look what
you're literally doing right now
your background of your screen is my
branding mechanism absolutely
so so i think you've got to think about
how to if you're willing to be the
content creator
i think that that is a very big and then
all you have to do this is very crazy
it's only two simple things it's gonna
sound so ridiculous like a grandmother
you have to be yourself and tell the
truth
now the way i'm myself is very unique
and that's probably why i've done well
you know when i speak the truth i also
have the skill set of seeing
you know i don't like to say i see
around corners but i put in a lot of
work to understand consumer behavior
earlier than other people and so between
my uniqueness and my truth which often
most people don't agree with at first
but then it becomes reputation when
you're right you need to develop that
over the next three to five years in the
marketplace where all these two problems
become a non-factor and i think you do
what i mean by non-factors it starts
coming to you instead of you chasing
the way you do that is in the
underpriced nature
of the social media platforms that are
winning in the country the end
for everybody here
and then and then real quick i apologize
because i'm answering a lot of times for
everybody because i want this to be very
valuable
and then when you pick let's say again
i'll just use christy because i am a
huge fan of red lights like like you
know what they're going to say on tick
tock which they know is more of a 15 to
30 year old crowd may be different than
the ad they put on on facebook which
might be older where they may tap into
nostalgia whereas with tick-tock they
may tap into something relevant in
culture
diff you know so you got to make
different content so if you go into
linkedin and make videos you're going to
talk differently than you are as a
pre-roll before a entrepreneurial piece
of content on youtube
i got it i got it thanks man i i really
wanted to kill it because
since the last four years this is what
brought our brand to the place that
so the key there is
is getting better at it
like even like like i've seen over the
last eight years with my brand and with
the businesses i'm associated with it
ebbs and flows
it ebbs and flows right we're about to
do a reorgan team gary
and i'm so confident
what's gonna happen and if i will be
better at it
in q4 of this year than i've been the
last year
because
we're just making a bigger commitment to
being even better on pinterest even
better i mean in the last month you know
last three weeks on tick tock i've done
so much better because we've made a
bigger commitment we were at a seven now
we're at an 8.5
and what peop when i hear what you just
said my concern is it's kind of like
exercise
you went from doing none of it
now you're now you're doing some
exercise which is amazing you're you're
you've lost that kind of ridiculous 10
extra pounds you really didn't need but
everybody here knows even if they're
good at working out they've got another
10 pounds
more cardio more muscle you could
you could and that's how i think about
social media content distribution you if
i can get much better the way i even
have in the last three weeks i can't
even imagine how much everybody else can
so i think pushing yourself further on
being a platform strategist really
understanding the products every
platform has and then trying new
platforms
especially when they have organic reach
and the big ones
like what my friend
huge i mean tick tock for you
i know it's exploded in the country
because we do the european business for
them and is a great avenue to require
new
agents who are young
yes i'm doing it already i still have
seven thousand followers only but i'm on
it but the good but the good thing with
tick tock is it does not have anything
to do with uh followers
it's completely it's completely interest
based
i literally my last two videos one got
24 000 views the next one got 7.9
million
it's completely interest-based i have
7.5 million followers i can get 25 000
views on a video because nobody gave a
[ __ ] got it thanks man love him cheers
love you back uh so we're gonna head up
to seattle and we're gonna talk to
jeremy real quick who has a question uh
for you before we head to ryan jeremy go
ahead
hey gary how are you thanks for the time
today so you know really focus for us is
on uh providing value to uh our
portfolio companies right and and the
guys that it's which james and joe just
been fantastic at helping and so
uh joe is allowing you to be selfish you
know for two minutes before it is that
we get to ryan so thanks for that
so um our business is investing into uh
making credit investments in the sme
market across the country right so if
you think about these companies that are
past that friends and family mom and dad
which uncle round are raising money but
they're really not yet to a point to
where the guys in chicago new york or
london can actually afford to pay
attention to them we're writing these
five seven ten million dollar checks
so
the the
i guess the two pieces it is for us is
really our audience by which it is that
we want to communicate and build
um either or either brand value or or
audience with is really the
uh family office wealth manager ultra
high net worth guys the institutions and
pensions are not our investors that's
just not how it is that we're set up
it's the so so so jeremy i apologize
you're we're now talking about not you
acquiring deal flow
but acquiring llps
acquiring lpng yeah exactly we we have a
uh an inordinate or a disproportionate
deficit to demand on deal flow right so
every dollar we get in the door we've
got about seven dollars looking for it
which is uh you know a first world
problem it's still a problem that first
world problem right
got it so so
you've got you've got
companies you actually want to invest in
so you just need more you want more
capital into the fund right so we're
raising capital into the fund and so the
two issues it is we run into is i spent
20 years as an investment banker before
moving from a advisor banker standpoint
investing principally off my balance
sheet and then raising a fund alongside
that and so
part of that is is going back to the
market and the constituents it is that
normally where the folks it is that
we're writing checks on our behalf
most of those guys
now we become competitors of right so
it's this strike friendly to a certain
degree but adversarial to a certain
degree as well
the
the challenges that we run into to a
certain degree is the credit landscape
is really made up of apollo and kkr and
carlisle in like the big 800 pound
gorillas and then a modicum of smaller
guys and there certainly is the adage as
you were growing up
that nobody ever got fired for investing
in apollo and so whereas
we may have something better and cooler
and faster and shinier and all this
other kind of [ __ ] the guy that's
managing half a billion dollars of
somebody else's money may love me but if
[ __ ] goes bad he could lose his job if
[ __ ] goes bad for putting 10 million
bucks on apollo nobody's gonna blink
i know it well i know your landscape
well i understand and then on the other
side of the equation
you have too many high net worth
individuals
who
want to do it themselves and don't want
to pay a big right like you know as
everyone you know it's kind of
for a lot of people especially in my
emerging class it's more fun to do it
themselves they want to do it themselves
so there's that kind of like sweet
middle that you really need to win on
right
yeah and i think that we've done a
good job of that and it's certainly not
a pat of any time but the the
the big headache it is that we had is
that ultimately we're going to make the
move it is to move out of the middle and
do from a principal position i wanted to
make sure that we created something that
was
markedly different than the other
thousand credit funds that are out there
because there's no point in just being
another [ __ ] flavor of vanilla ice
cream right like so we got french
vanilla and vanilla bean
like no not
yep yes
the the contra by which it is that we
created i think while i'm confident
creates a degree of parity it is that
becomes attractive to the family office
offices because we're not locking up
capital long term i'm not charging him a
management fee we're not using leverage
all of those normal points of
consternation it is that you have
between so
so so you're winning on the product
right you're winning on the financial
arbitrage you've got a better financial
you know opportunity for the person on
the other side totally yep
now what what what's the size of the
check of norm currently of like normal
lps and and are they really for the most
part family offices or do you get some
high net worth individuals who don't
want to do the work or have their own
family office and view you as a good
option yeah so individuals so for the
the old rich guy kind of individual
checks these are you know 100 grand to
maybe a million
for the
family offices and that kind of thing
these are two to five two to seven
million dollar checks a piece and then
ultimately on the other side the
portfolio companies that is what we're
investing in i'm writing kind of two to
ten million dollar checks
jeremy i think um you know just to get
the punchline because i've got enough
context i think the biggest thing that
people don't understand is every company
in the world right now is actually a
media company
like when i think about your business i
say to myself even the way you were just
talking which built up this it probably
would have been my answer anyway but it
gave me more conviction
you know i say to myself [ __ ] if i can
convince jeremy
to do a podcast and interview
entrepreneurs lps family office
executives you'd be stunned guys and
gals who have not returned your email
even with a good career that you've had
to your point because it's just you know
it is what it is you'd be stunned
if there's that plum family office and
that person you kind of want to have a
relationship with and he kind of knew
him from back in the day but they just
have a big response and when your email
in the title says hey carl hey kyla
would love to have you on the guest of
my podcast to talk about family offices
you would be flabbergasted i mean
people like like because if you have the
dna of mark cuban or ray dalio or mike
novogratz or michael rubin you actually
say nut yes to these things like i watch
this this is like my great
fascination of how big this arbitrage is
you can't get the four people i just
mentioned ever you're a cockamanian tier
4 podcast and you say you want to be on
and one out of nine times they say yes
so for me
why i like that is not only do i want
you to do that podcast and kind of vary
on a hot take intuitively think you
should be the host of it and then you do
successful entrepreneurs like the one
you have here
in that stage
taste makers from the game like me for
awareness
literally
literally the people you're trying to
say have you know sell to as a guest
which is like a mitzvah and a half
and
and and then what's really cool is
linkedin
is such good organic reach it's
people are going to cry in 10 years when
they realize they missed this golden era
of linkedin that happened in 2017
through 2023
where you can just post and people would
see it
and then much like the content model i
do not only do you do that
the whole episode
but you take one little clip where
somebody says something viral you chat
that up
you get one viral clip on linkedin you'd
be
i don't know how to say it other than
you'd be downright fascinated
how easy it is to close business uh you
know what the comp is it's the media
equivalent of how sad it is that
sometimes getting sidelined passes to a
football game taking somebody out for a
golfing round to a club you can't get
into having a safe dinner with a 4 000
bottle of wine because the person is a
huge wine collector
humans make ridiculous big business
decisions predicated on very little
proxies that just happen to hit them on
their interests
for you
you know
the right clip of a family office person
getting a 100 000 views on a linkedin
and then getting an email from a buddy
that they admire or someone they admire
or old college friends saying you looked
great on the show you'd be stunned where
your firm would be in two years
it's always the same game the first two
answers build the moat
that comes to you but what's amazing
about what i'm telling you to do here is
you're actually hosting the dinner party
you're throwing the high school party
your podcast
you're gonna get the people you're
trying to sell to be your guests
yeah and so we're doing the podcast now
so we're about 15 or 17 episodes in of
exact that strategy that you're talking
about and ryan's come on let's let let's
break it down the 15-17
how many of those guests are actually
the decision maker at a family office
that you would like to do business with
um of the family offices none so this
has been other
fund managers entrepreneurs big business
guys friends of ours that we've helped
go public that kind of a thing first
right rather than yep
i want you i want you now that you have
15 17 in of the next third 15 guests i
want five of them to literally be
the human that you want to pitch to be
part of your fund but none of that gets
brought up in recording them to be on
the show
perfect can't do it where are are you
posting clips
of the podcast in video or audio form
for its entirety on linkedin from your
company's profile or your profile
links to the entirety yes not um
not chopping it up it is in little bite
size pieces and doing it across so
you're put you're posting a link to the
audio
out of linkedin correct
that's that's correct haven't chopped it
up and done that purely just from
[ __ ] resources to be honest with you
more you know
that's the answer
the investment of the resources to make
sure it's done on video you presume in
real life
to then put fully in video and fully
five clips per episode into linkedin
because it gets crazy or not jeremy you
can then run ads against employees of
organizations
so check this out now you did the video
thing that i need you to do
now there's a good clip that organically
did well which the market then tells you
affirmation then you take that clip and
you run it against all of the employees
of apollo blackrock all of the you know
some of the firms you're going at better
family offices might be big enough to
hit the radar on linkedin targeting
it's really quite scary how effective
this actually is
excellent thank you
right you're welcome and uh we're gonna
zip over to ryan hogan who's one of
jeremy's investments at uh hunterkiller
ryan go ahead
ryan give me the context of what you're
sending people
yeah sure so it's evolved over the years
we initially started off as a well i i
guess if you if you rewind about seven
years ago i used to have an event called
run fear lies which was the first ever
zombie infested 5k obstacle course race
we scaled that nationwide back in 2011
um 12 we had our peak year 13 that um
that whole
scene collapsed
tough mudder and warrior dash made it
through a few more years
um but when we did it
did it did it collapse because there was
too much supply
uh
like every [ __ ] like every like there
was like 900 of them
yeah i mean not only were we competing
at that point with warrior dash and
tough mudder but then every farm started
seeing you know tens of thousands of
people on their property over any given
weekend um and felt that they could do
it themselves and then and then color
run and and foam run and everything else
coming in
um
so fast forward to 2016
um
we launched another event called hunter
killer and hunter killer was basically
we use the same sort of concept that we
used in 2010 which is we looked across
the industry at different types of
experiences that people were gravitating
towards
2016 was
you know the off-broadways
immersive theater like
sleep no more um you've got escape rooms
coming over from europe and asia you've
got um
uh obstacle races which are still kind
of prevalent and so for us it was all
about okay well how do we take these
three things combine them into just one
gigantic immersive live experience um
and that's when hunterkiller um
came about and we transformed a 200 acre
campground into a living crime scene
um the first event went great the
problem was is that it just didn't scale
so when you think back to obstacle races
you we can make a million million and a
half in any given weekend for this to
keep it immersive and and distort
reality we couldn't have thousands of
people sitting around um
a a staged crime scene
um and so we looked at a different type
of business model 2016 loot crates birch
boxes everything else we said okay let's
evolve this immersive storytelling
concept into a subscription box platform
um we did that and and that really
became uh the flagship of hunter killer
which was episodic deliveries each month
of
uh clues items and correspondence that
arrived directly to our detective's
doorsteps um it went great over the the
next few years but we saw the same thing
that um both birchbox and loot crates
and everybody else that's in that space
which is you're just it's a game of
increasing pack and and trying to to
fight off churn
uh so for us it was about
diversification um and different things
that we could do so you know right now
our focus is really on diversification
of revenue streams we're currently
sitting on the shelves of target um
amazon we've got licensing deals with
nancy drew agatha christie um
how much
how much is it
uh depends on the experience so if it's
a subscription um it's 30 bucks a month
if you're buying us off the the shelves
of targets 30 for a single experience
once episodic the other is all than one
i understand keep going so
um
i guess that was the the whole
background the future for us is really
about digital um you know licensing is
going great from an inbound standpoint
now we're really looking at outbound at
the heart we are a media company we've
known since day one we're a media and
entertainment company and so other ways
that we can monetize and license that um
is very interesting to us
have you thought about standing up
original characters from the original
game and launching an nft project
we're not we're not that sophisticated
again yeah we haven't felt that
good yeah
yeah what's crazy what's crazy about it
what's crazy about it is
it's you know i've done 51 million
dollars in revenue on v friends in the
first 68 days
now
before you say yes you had a big
platform this and that board ape yacht
club
which came out of nowhere has done
hundreds of millions in the same 67 days
if you were to take
and create your versions of colonel
mustard
and sherlock holmes and really go deep
into character creation because you're
right you know
you know you know what's happening with
nancy drew and all that you become a
platform with them dilution over
saturation and you know and you you've
been through two rodeos of over supply
and saturation so you know exactly
what's going to happen with the
licensing part it'll be that continued
game you can run that game longer
but
but what you want to be
is the brand more so than renting out
the
you know the platform i think and
i think you're stepping in poop right
now
being part of this for these in the
moment where i think i'm sitting at the
forefront of the knowledge base of this
and i think your game and your whole
concept that you are a media company
like you have to make a movie a
television show a netflix show a video
game an iphone game or an nft project or
you're not gonna get you're gonna get to
some sort of new version of what you
felt already twice which is fine i
already know why jeremy invested in you
like you show me an entrepreneur that
continues to pivot and i'll show you and
actually successfully pivot for moments
of time i'll show you an entrepreneur
that's
somewhere along the line going to find
the thing that they don't have to pivot
out of so i love it i'm like listening
with like smiles i really think you need
to spend 25 hours of your personal time
in the next two weeks three weeks and
really understand what the [ __ ] is going
on with nfts because i think you can
change your business forever
interesting
um
that's a hard pivot i i wasn't expecting
to get an nfp so yeah i mean i'll be
honest with you it's not even because i
have a bug for nfts right now it's
because i know what's going on i know
that if you have the creative chops
which i don't know if you do or don't or
if you teamed up with somebody did that
could create
call it 25 core characters from this
game
and then you made you know 400 tokens of
each of them made a 10 000 token play
and went into the crypto punk sport api
club
kind of you know uh environment uh that
if god forbid aka god willing
it went viral not only would you make
millions on that execution it would then
trickle down to your core business and
give you a spike in that business that
you wouldn't even understand
interesting
um and the other interesting part i mean
the the television shows the the book
deals we've got a book deal with
scholastic it'll hit shelves this um
this fall so like we're doing all of
those things which is very exciting but
we don't necessarily own it so it's what
you're talking about we're continuing to
build the hunting killer brand is
extremely important
um it's the only it's actually the only
thing you have
like i don't care what you're doing
currently with it
like i do because you do and jeremy does
because that's your current p l but in
real life
you're in the smurfs scooby doo v
friends pokemon
sherlock holmes
you know nancy drew business
and and
you've gotta
triple down on that part
not
hey we don't have a big enough brand we
have this idea
oh we're good sales people and tenacious
entrepreneurs and we're getting
intellectual property to rent with us jb
it's giving us exposure but every human
really sees you as an afterthought when
they buy it at target it's they're not
buying you they're buying nancy
um and you've got to become intel right
like like nobody thought about chips
inside in that scenario like you'd have
to build the brand of we're powering all
these things which i think is a very
diminishing return hard game or you get
people to really give a [ __ ] about
donald the detective
through this incredible arbitrage called
nfts which then trickles down
to your core business
profitably you like make a ton of money
if you hit
on the nft
it's something i really really want you
to spend 25 hours on for a million
different reasons it will be by the way
this is the answer to everybody from
including jeremy who's in finding like
this is something that has to be
understood the way that internet 1.0 had
to and the way that social media had to
there's very big things going on in that
world
it is far it's the furthest thing from a
fad that i can think of
the question becomes do you have the
character development capabilities and
if you don't how do you do that because
that'll be part of the equation you know
i guess the the other question i would
have is outside of nfts i i mean you're
you're deeply familiar with the space
and the headwinds that direct consumer
has right now you know as we look at
people um uh reintegrating into society
as we look at
um facebook and privacy and everything
else that's going on right ios 14 ios 14
is a challenge no remarketing uh i would
become a master expert in tik tok ads
and organic niche
your business can explode and whether to
storm if you became exceptional at insta
at tick tock influencer creator
marketing and
my preference which is where i started
right
is that they're talking about donald the
detective
not necessarily
the
you know the [ __ ] nemo version of the
platform i mean
because i want you to win twice i don't
want you to just win on the short-term
tackle tv business i want to get you
religious about what you're actually
doing
right like like
you know i would tell you that for
example but james on the call here
james
gary you went on mute yeah you went on
mute for some reason yeah sorry about
that
i'll tell you why i did my pinky touched
it sorry about everyone you know james's
career with me
has been different than the way he's
navigated because i was playing a
different game of brand not operational
p l so there was probably a lot of you
know i'm speaking for him maybe he'll
bring it up later there was probably
unique decisions at the time that felt
foreign or different or he's a bright
dude so he was like i wonder why he's
doing that i'm sure i'll think you know
i went through it right wrong or
indifferent worked or didn't it was that
i was religious about knowing what i was
building
and
you know for for me what excites me
about your business my friend is if
you're religious about understanding
you need to create characters in your
game that people like the fact that i
can bring up colonel buster is the
reason clue still sells
yep
um
great points and a part of that is uh in
the life can i give you a ride can i
give you guys i apologize can i give you
a left field one the reason i want you
to make
like
is
you
let you make a halloween costume like
i'm going to be doing with v friends
you can grab tick tock influencers
you don't want to wear it that becomes
your own
and your business forever has changed
by developing the characters you go into
the home run business anything then can
happen right now you're in the morrison
birchbox i was i wrote the first check
in the birchbox you can google the story
it was at starbucks they tried
like the reason it lost
is when you're in the conversion sales
business not the overall brand business
you eventually die
yeah
um
it's why mascots work right
and i just think you have a huge
opportunity because you are in the media
business
but i don't but i want your characters
to not be like faceless does that make
sense
yeah and i mean do you think that they
become the sub brand of hunt the killer
like
hunt the killer becomes the umbrella in
which they are always a part of of
course of course you've heard of disney
but you also know who mickey mouse is
and let me give you some news mickey
mouse and snow white is why you know
disney not the other way around
all right guys we got to move forward um
thank you very much ryan for sharing
that uh russell uh down in california
you're up next
i apologize russell before you go ryan
one last thought
which is to the question you thought
we're gonna answer it will be tick tock
ads that saved your butt on ltd
thanks
that was the main question
i know it was which is why i brought it
to the end
good russell
excellent thanks gary so
we are
my company ymash capital is a mortgage
broker in the bay area
we are more of a b2b model than b yep
i'm aware um and so what we do is we
partner with tax pros and financial
planners get them licensed and teach
them how to provide mortgages for their
clients
this is important because it is illegal
to pay someone a referral fee in our
industry so they actually have to do
they have to do the work and what i did
is i actually created a proprietary
system that makes it very easy for them
to do all the steps and do all the work
without actually really knowing
everything
okay
i understand
cool
um so i started working in this family
business in 1991
came up with these ideas that everyone
said no you can't do it that way and you
know i did all the research and over
several years came up with the systems
um
in 2015 the founders decided to retire
and i was passed over to inherit the
company
it was given to my little brother and
the other found her son
my father was one of the founders okay
in 2018 they fired me kicked me out of
here
and my wife and i
i'm sorry why
they didn't like the fact that
the ip was owned by another company
where i was one of the owners we have a
software company
so they decided
they decided i was a danger because i
had
ownership in the tools that made them
all their money so
they knew i had permission to start my
own company anytime i wanted to and
actually take the iq with
i think so they they were they refined
me in 2018
um
my wife and i started a new company
tried more in 2018 which is another
brokerage which is tiny
because it's really hard to start from
zero you know that um
and then
my brother and his partner realized they
don't like running a company
they don't like mortgages
so i bought them out may 1st of last
year
interesting okay
um last year was the company's best year
since 2012.
um back in 2012 the company was twice as
big so i've brought some different
changes that i wanted to do now that
it's mine
um i changed the compensation plan for
the agents i'm reaching out a lot more
to my agents trying to make them feel
supported
you're running the action you're
actually running the business
that's what i'm doing and and there's
been a lot of mismanagement over the
years right yep um so i'm trying to do
everything i can to increase morale it's
been really tough since we can't get
together you know because we were
basically forced to close
right before i took over
um and so everything's been virtual now
instead of meeting in person um right
but i try to reach out to all my best
people several times a week hey how's it
going do you need anything
um i i made sure to meet with each of
them at christmas time went to their
homes and brought them a gift which the
company's never done just all kinds of
stuff
good news i've got the i've got the full
context of this story let's get into the
question i understand
so
my question is because what we do is a
little bit too late
how do i get the message out to the
independent cpas taxpayers financial
planners to entice them into listening
to the message so they want to offer the
service to their clients
um
have do you know what is going on with
facebook groups
um i'm in several facebook groups so
what do you mean
i believe that facebook groups for this
kind of scenario are an incredible super
weapon
i think your company should start
many facebook groups
and you should hire
after
you know
you either you
or because you've got you've got what
i've got which is like you like scaling
unscalable things
yeah because you know that's because you
know that's how business is done so now
what i'm gonna do for you is try to give
you a model that scales unscalable
things that are still unscalable but are
much more scalable than what you're
doing right
facebook groups so for example a couple
questions
is the business regional by nature or no
so
each state has its own licensing
requirements so we are in
california and utah right now
perfect let's start there let's just
start there
i think you should take the seven
biggest cities in those two or the seven
your favorite cities to target because
maybe s7 la and even salt lake city
might be too competitive but let me tell
you what i would do
i
if you create many different facebook
groups
that are either broad
or narrow
right so
uh the salt literally this is what you
name your group the salt lake city
mortgage and real estate
friends group that's it okay
then you run facebook ads
against real estate employees or real
estate interests or whatever the
targeting capabilities are on facebook
right now
in that area
right you promote it you look at your
current business and figure out what
city it like
what what i want you to do is get the
industry
into your facebook group where you're
the host
a bigger
slightly different
version of what i just told jeremy to do
journey higher touch bigger checks i
want him to host the party own the
podcast
i know what he's done for his 15 17 yes
but notice the little tweak jeremy two
things you gotta get the fun man you
gotta get the decision maker to be your
guest because you're gonna get a
relationship and you need to make video
and create content for you
i want you to stand up facebook groups i
believe facebook groups is one of the
incredible arbitrages because you're
basically becoming the pta the chamber
of commerce
virtually the virality russell is insane
if you run ads and spend 2 thousand
bucks and get 91 people let me say that
number again 91 people
into that facebook group
for the fresno
real estate and mortgage friends group
you are going to wake up if you work it
put in put in questions say hi to people
if you're working which is why you have
to scale this a little bit
you will wake up one day in
seven months and go how the hell does
this have 9 000 people in it
okay
what's amazing about that 500 700 9 000
people is they're so targeted
and just like the book i wrote jab jab
jab right hook when you're just putting
out good information you're talking
about the market you're talking about
family work life balance
it's a friends group
you're jabbing but then every 12th time
first of all they're going to look at
your bio who's this guy that started the
group and in your bio you're gonna have
a link to your business you're not even
gonna have to [ __ ] say it they're
gonna start asking you questions like
russell what do you do
you will be flabbergasted what a
facebook group can do for your business
model
awesome that's a completely different
direction than i thought you were going
to take me so
cool
good it's been invaluable
right for the last
you know
it's always like where do you think and
you've got the rest of my team there
because i put out enough information on
that you can brush your teeth and eyes
the rest of the day but again much like
nfts for the last answer please spend
russell and i know you will already
which is why i love the context the
first three minutes
spend 10 hours
meeting and watching youtube videos
about facebook groups
don't pay for [ __ ] don't pay for
[ __ ] courses from all those internet
spammers there's plenty of good
information on youtube of how to run a
facebook group but it will work brother
it will work if you make them very
regional don't make it california
because now you compete it's too general
you want to win regionally got it fresno
sacramento you can go even smaller you
may know where there's a hot pocket
where you want to do business or where
you used to do business really well and
you want to reboot it it could be a
[ __ ]
city it doesn't even have to be
you know like you can go very narrow if
you want
that's how you can do it but then you've
got to be the pied piper and the mayor
in there
or start to hire one person underneath
you to scale it
very cool
thank you very much
it's gonna work you're welcome awesome
you're welcome next we're gonna talk to
dylan dylan who's also in california sag
to garyvee
hey gary hey dylan
so i fire with my question right now
right
yep
all right awesome so i have two main
questions one release to branding uh the
other one really to um hiring and
training so i'll follow with the
branding first so
um from you know the way that you do
branding gary i can see it's somewhat it
has a really big overlap between your
business and also your branding you know
audience
people that are entrepreneurs people
that are you know what are hustlers
right
so i feel like there's a good mix there
for me um you know our product is teeth
grinding and when it comes to content
there's just so much you can talk about
when it comes you know bruxism teeth
grinding stress
so one of the things i thought about was
you know talk about things that people
that are integrating might be interested
in what our targeted audience would be
interesting maybe you know when we run
ads we can see the demographics and
interest and all of that so we create
other related type of topic to talk
about uh you know like
maybe yoga maybe meditation
maybe you know stress
management but not really training right
so my question is how do i play the game
of personal branding versus business
branding so i can come from the angle of
personal branding and talk you know even
talk about things that aren't related to
you know our dental business at all
maybe just talk about my
uh challenges as a business owner yeah
four four four or like i do with the
jets and garage saleing or
you know wine or that you like fishing
the answer is going to be both dylan i
am blown away by people's um fascination
with or
the answer is
both
and right
you do that
yeah you and the companies handle
right doing the best it can
yes by the way i don't want to be a dead
horse i genuinely believe your product
could go viral on tick tock
okay we're showing that with harvest
dental right now gary and uh a couple a
couple people on tick tock doing a lot
of stuff with dentures believe it or not
okay thanks for the answer so not at all
but where are you i mean one of the
first major
take top freaks
hey gary we lost you might want to turn
your video off for a minute to let your
food back up can you guys hear me
yeah we can hear you now
okay go ahead
oh um i i lost you for a while there i i
i wasn't really i thought it was my
internet connection problem
it was it was mine dylan so yes the
answer is both
and and i bring up the tick tock thing
because i and james brought up the
dental thing
i think you can really
if any consumer product like you
especially yours at the price range and
what the benefits are for stress mental
health like you can make one video once
you understand tik tok which may take
several months
that's like cramming for your tests and
struggling it's actually your teeth
grinding and for some reason
it just goes it you can't believe what
i'm seeing
with one post on tick tock changing dtc
business results
yeah that was that was very interesting
we mentioned about one video you had
over a million view the other one was
just 27 000 where you know it's interest
based not followed based so definitely
testing that out um the second question
is actually related to
um you know we'll just talk about which
is the video going virals which is our
production capacity because everything
is handcrafted um so you know the
scaling of the business is is
changes strongly on how much production
how many you know trained technicians we
can hire and train
um here in the bay area you know cost is
relatively high
and as a technician
uh you know you're really not gonna get
paid a lot of money initially because
it's a skill based so you're you acquire
skill as you you know um as time go on
so
it's not a really attractive of career
per se initially because you know you're
really just being a um
what is apprentice
um initially so
the
uh our hiring and training strategy
right now with you know one of the
points i picked up you know one of the
earlier answers you you had to uh the
other um i forgot his name but the first
one the best yeah invest heavily on
heavy training if
you if you and george made content
that
that
i'm gonna be paying you
for me to train you
your whole deal flow of talent would
change if you and george made the same
[ __ ] video
that said we have done this
internally in our company
so that we're literally paying you while
we're actually training you
so not like college where you pay to get
something that helps you get a job we're
gonna be paying you on your job and
we're gonna be training you you'll have
a totally different funnel of people
coming to you
right
yeah that's a good point uh that's you
just i think that's you you just have to
make you have to make those videos
you have to put them on youtube facebook
and linkedin and get good at it tick
tock and then that will then change that
flow it will work
thanks for uh confirming that yeah so um
that's one of the things we played uh
not play but one of the factors we
stress during the interviewing process
explaining to them why their initial pay
is low because of their lot of training
a lot of education going on and um um
yeah i think that's the next thing we're
going to be doing is actually launching
some campaign like you said the paid ad
campaigns and really target the people
in our local area and talk about this
point and some of the other key points
of why they should start a career as a
dental technician and really play that
yeah
make the video punchy fast and
contextual
send it to a landing page that explains
it in detail the mistake that most
people make in your situation is they
try to explain everything in the video
and then the video doesn't do well make
the video interesting
thumb stopping
with a link to the full description
right
sounds good
um
that's really all i have thanks a lot
good we had a quick follow on about uh
how to find influencers in each of their
niche is there any recommendations you
have is it work with an outsourced
agency is there a tool you prefer
when you say out what do you would i
want to make sure to get clarity on that
can we get clarity on that when you say
influencers
we're talking jeremy now like guests
like what jimmy are you asking like the
guests that you're looking for no when
you're talking to christy and each of
these guys you're talking to identify
the you know the topic yes got it got it
got it um
and find those guys
if you go to google right now and you
say the top followed people on tick tock
or the top ranking podcasters you
literally have your answer in two hours
awesome thank you thanks gary
and then what happened usually those
lists are only top 100 or top 1000
journey and then you start digging right
you you start looking like like you get
into the trenches of instagram and tick
tock and you just start clicking around
like who's following who and what and
you just see verified check marks and
you start just it's actually like
research work you know but it's all
there
all right team looking forward to it um
i uh i i apologize that we ran out of
time but that's in a weird way ace jamie
that's gonna end up being good news
because i have a weird feeling it's
gonna work out for you so i'll see you
soon
thank you thank you thank you
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times uh i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my commitment and
exploration of youtube is about to
explode stories polls more content more
engagement more surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you